this is um  probably the most difficult connection  that the  boring company will have to make the  most difficult tunnel they've ever built  because it is a very tight turn from  where our station is the convention  center to  run on to  las vegas boulevard  and not only very tight turn  horizontally but they were also diving  at the same time so they were basically  boring a corkscrew  and  it is the tightest that that machine  will actually turn  and a very difficult process it was very  slow as a result because not only are  they doing that corkscrew but they're  doing it through a layer of caliche  and that's one of the hardest materials  out there to get through so  you add all those things up and they've  probably taken the biggest test that  they can take in past